in about two months we'll all be playing
cicchitto a game that's really shaking
the foundations of the souls born
franchise and the hardest thing for this
community to wrap its head around has
been the lack of RPG elements cicchitto
has no stat level up screen you're
forced to use a katana and there are
fewer gear choices but recently it has
been revealed that Sookie Rose still has
a surprising amount of character
customization no you can't dress up as
an onion of the day poor princess
Lautrec but you can level up your
character you can diversify your play
style and you can even spec into
different combos and special attacks
this is all done for the first time with
something simply called
experience as you kill enemies you'll
rack up experience points which actually
aren't lost upon death unlike in other
souls games once you have enough you
head back to the hub world and then you
invest them into three talent trees one
of these trees is called shinobi another
one is called prosthetic and the third
is called samurai it reminds me a lot of
World of Warcraft's old talent system
you know back when World of Warcraft
didn't feel like a mobile game so just
like this actually these talent trees
will contain both active abilities that
you can unlock and also passive effects
that you can invest in so let's take the
shinobi talent tree for example from
what I understand this would enhance
things like your critical strikes your
stealth basically everything assassin
related take wall-jumping for example
this would be an example of a active
ability and an example of a passive
shinobi ability might be reducing your
aggro range during stealth something
like that I'm sure you guys can think of
more second the prosthetic talent tree
this one's pretty self-explanatory an
active ability in this tree might be
unlocking combo attacks for your
prosthetics like how flame vent can set
your sword on fire or how your shuriken
arm can follow up with a katana
a passive effect in this tree would be
increasing the amount of shriek ins
thrown for example as seen here or maybe
reducing the amount of spirit emblems
you need to activate an attack and third
the samurai talent tree which I think
will be my favorite is likely going to
focus on general combat so in terms of
active abilities we know already that
there are special attacks that you can
perform by holding down r1 and l1 like
this cross slash attack for example so I
bet there will be tons of other
varieties to unlock in this tree an
example of a passive ability in this
tree might be making you deal more
posture damage or allowing your healing
gourd to replenish more health and
apparently with another experience you
can actually upgrade every talent in
this tree and 100% complete your
character but it's unlikely that you'll
be able to do this in a single
playthrough and experience isn't the
only form of currency there's also gold
another static resource that we use to
trade with vendors there's even
apparently crafting materials that we
can use to enhance our prosthetic arm so
this is pretty great the more you
explore the world the more enemies you
fight and the more you enhance your
character and diversify your play style
you can lament the loss of a stat system
or you like really but you kind of have
to admit grinding for a new attack or a
new skill it's a bit more exciting than
grinding to upgrade one point of
dexterity not that I leveled X or
anything leveling up is done at the hub
location which is called the dilapidated
temple a place located on the Agena
outskirts and like in other games npcs
will occasionally travel here for quests
or for trading but we already know of
three who will be there every time
first the sculptor as expected he's the
one we go to to upgrade our prosthetic
arm with materials that we find
throughout the world
second there's going to be a woman there
named Emma she's responsible for
upgrading the amount of charges your
healing gourd can contain upgraded with
an item called
spirit water drops and third and my
favorite the immortal soldier I love
this basically his a swordsman
that's incapable of dying and so he
serves as a sort of human training dummy
who we can whale on and practice our
move set with I really hope he wins is
about it like crestfallen would I have a
feeling that'll be the same sort of
character and being able to practice
combat here is way way way more
important in cicchitto than it has been
in other souls games because in
cicchitto the hub will also be the place
where we invest in skill trees and
abilities that fundamentally change the
way our character plays so it makes
sense to be able to test these in a safe
environment outside of the talent tree
if you want a permanent upgrade to your
health or posture this is done through
an item called prayer beads apparently
these are commonly dropped by mini
bosses in cicchitto and that's a good
reason to fight these mini bosses
instead of running past them because yes
running past things is probably gonna be
pretty effective in this game
according to Miyazaki the environments
are fairly open in the beginning but he
also said that they really open up
around the halfway mark in the game and
open up they should because not only can
we grapple over things we can swim
that's right
no longer do we need to fear knee-deep
water imagine sneaking into a castle via
a water duct or fighting a boss that
swims beneath you
in Game Informer's two-hour session
sekito explored the Hirata
estates and the name Hirata should be
familiar to some of you who watched this
video apparently we travel back to this
place in a memory and this is accessed
via the hub world which raises the
question by visiting this memory are we
simply reliving something that has
already happened or are we capable of
going back in time to change the past
and considering we still have our ninja
prosthetic in all of these scenes I'm
leaning towards the latter I think we
might be able to change things here the
village is being razed to the ground
by drunken bandits I can't wait to
figure out why second mini-bosses of
this stage is one of these drunken
bandits
his name is Jews oh the drunkard in his
second phase he spits poison onto his
weapon which means it will probably
damage you if you try to parry him and
this is a cool example of how they can
subvert the core gameplay in cicchitto
because everyone's playing in a similar
way so everyone is going to have to find
a way around this regardless of your
built apparently during this mini boss
you can find a nearby NPC who will help
you during this fight but since there's
no summoning system in sukira you know
there's no one line there's no soap
stones or anything reports say that if
this NPC dies during the fight it might
be permanent not everyone is undead this
time you have to remember and the
concept of death permanence in cicchitto
for NPCs at least could mark a pretty
huge departure from all of the years and
years of undead characters we've had
with souls games in those games it was
often difficult to pin down a canon
death for the character but in cicchitto
with well-defined death comes more
emotional stories and speaking of
emotion apparently some of these NPCs
now have their own soundtracks
we've known for a while that the music
is being composed by the legendary
Yukari Tamura who has done in-house
music for many from games before this
and she's going to have her hands full
because there's more music in this game
than in any other previous title not
only is that the music for boss battles
there is music during stealth during
combat during exploration and there are
even songs created for specific
characters said to enhance the emotions
associated with their stories and as
someone who spends hours and hours
finding the perfect music to suit these
characters in prepare to cry this last
point makes me pretty excited think how
fitting
Gwyn's theme is for his character and
then apply that to some of your
favourite characters in these games they
kind of all deserve all of this pales in
comparison
perhaps the biggest news this week
cicchitto has a pause button I'll just
let that sink in a bit it actually makes
more sense in this game since sake dough
is about killing ingeniously you can
apparently pause and get an opportunity
to rifle through your equipment and your
items for a solution to your problem the
biggest curiosity that remains I think
is the death penalty Miyazaki himself
recently said that it's still taking
shape and it's very unique and it's more
personal than ever before and he also
said that it's not just going to be the
classic corpse run to retrieve your
souls
so what could it be I want you guys to
help me out with this one
I reckon together we'll probably stumble
across it so here are my current ideas
first since Miyazaki says that the death
penalty for dying is more personal then
I think perhaps it's our prince who is
keeping us alive with his blood our
prince after all in the last trailer
said wolf along with my blood you must
live I wouldn't be surprised if with
every death we weaken our Prince or
perhaps with every death we develop a
more difficult world state you know just
like world tendency in Demon Souls
perhaps enemies grow stronger every time
we die since we pray to these statues
which are called demon Buddha statues
what if sukira himself becomes more
demon like with every death imagine a
sort of deal with the devil every time
you die and finally blood-borne had an
insight meter what if our perception of
the world changes negatively with every
death these are some ideas can you think
of others let me know in the comments
below and if you're watching this video
as it goes live right now chances are
I'm streaming right now so come over to
twitch and say hi I'll see you all next
time
[Music]